Here is an example from UML. It concerns a a machine,
that's either heating or cooling. It's some kind of air-conditioning system.
And on the lower right is a nested state called heating.
Heating is just a two state sub-system.
One of the states is activating, and the others is called act,
active. Okay, it's got a default state which is the activating state, and
it's got a transition which occurs when the activating is ready.
And it the action that takes place is to, to turn things on.
This nested state is part of the larger system, which at the top
level has three important states. It has an idol state, a cooling state, and
this nested heating state. The default state for the larger machine is idle, and
the final state is a shutdown state. And there are transitions
between the various outer states. But notice also the transitions that
from the nested heating state, go only to the boundary of that state and
not into the internals of that state. Thereby saving duplicate copies
of the lines coming from each of the internal states in the heating state.